[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les enfants lolo euros notre
nounours et d'humeur joyeuse ce soir ils
ont envie de trop seul patron va danser
nounours nicolas et pimprenelle seront
sûrement très content et tous nos petits
amis aussi car je suis sûr qu'ils
adorent danser d'homologues lololol
bérulle josh formidable
alors on va tous dansé ensemble album
[Musique]
both worlds gens gentils très sage
nounours je pensais pas l'air je me suis
bien avec les deux mais on a mangé au
couteau l'enfant exemple
alors qu'est ce qu'on est et 6 1 qui va
danser avec wayne john l'on chérit petit
ornements ils me prennent part les
sentiments est bien d'accord
visite baills trop lisse moi je réponds
gendt aujourd'hui avec les petites
recettes magiques on ne peut pas se
tromper une fois non lama mais surtout
tenez vous bien
d'abord on va tourner et par là de se
voter mais gentiment sans bousculade on
va s'arrêter à dire de l'autre côté on
nous fait une promenade
mais c'est chan et jet li année à moisie
c'est ça vous plaît tant mes enfants où
je n'ai pas réussi un petit tour par ici
vous voudrez et c'est réussi
maintenant on chante on sent qu'à
en avant les bons danseurs
breux voleuse au fond vous dont sucre
bien un
elle est très jolie d'achat sans lui
nous comme tu chantes bien où chante là
encore est que tu te fois dans notre
chambre et on se couche au site ou bien
tu apprenais halle et dépêche-toi nounou
aux saisons saisons font attention
musique maestro clusaz
[Musique]
moi je vais manger aujourd'hui avec les
petits pour ne pas se tromper une fois
nolan et surtout tenez vous bien
d'abord on va tourner et par là de ce
côté mais gentiment sans tout ce qu'il a
on va s'arrêter tir de l'autre bout des
seins nous fait une de promenade
les chars légers ameziane voisine c'est
ça mon plan mes enfants venez pas
baisser un petit tour par six veuves ou
dream est serré usines de pâte dans
chantons de pourcentage en avant les
bons dans ça
et maintenant on oublie le pont dans ce
ballet jargonneux nombre de nuits les
petits
[Musique]
j'éteins la lune heures faites haut
il est quand même gentil nous et nous
pas prenez 5 micola et pourrait pas
prenez
et
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit les petits danseurs fermé
vite vos jolis yeux
il est l'heure de faire de beaux rêves
allons en route
maître à danser route pas trop bonne
nuit des enfants à demain à thomas
bonneau
[Musique]